[Music]
mr. nightmare
I had better nightmares
Hey so that thing just stop doing
whatever the hell oh my god
whatever signal was said and finally
crapped up I thought we bypassed the
battery oh we did it's still plugged in
and just just stop rebooted send the
signal again yeah well we don't even
know what this is
fury did just do it please tell me the
second you get a signal I want to know
who's on the other end of that thing
where's fury so strolls are the bad guys
and you're a tree a race of noble
warriors heroes noble warrior here is
Captain Marvel is a character in our
comics and mythology who's got one foot
on earth one foot in a cosmic arena so
this story was the right one he
introduced the overarching narrative of
the crease World War background and
actions it's inspired by of economics
but at a whole other level
I'm not gonna fight your war I'm gonna
end it
the Marvel Cinematic Universe has had so
many iconic villains the girls are super
interesting villains to us because they
can they can turn into anyone I'll tell
you my secret when you told me yours
Scrolls might be the most famous alien
race and the Marvel Comics they're
shapeshifters and very important to the
mythology scrolls can get inside you
there's a line so this might scroll very
formidable because of their camouflage
ability they've evolved in such
different ways than the Kree and the
humans they can be your mother your
father your brother they're like the
best size in the world because they can
literally be anybody strolls have
invaded yet another border planet
the relentless scroll expansion
dangerously nears our territory what's
very clever about storytelling in
Captain Marvel is that you're fed the
propaganda of one nation and believe
that the scrolls are the bad guys
but you're already seeing it through the
kree's always as we meet the Cree in
this movie they're technologically
driven and very much motivated by this
war which has kind of become pervasive
to their entire society the Cree are a
very dominant and very aggressive race
and their military and their leaders
conduct themselves as such the Cree are
really incredible warriors hyper
intellectuals and also totally devoid of
emotion you lied to me I made you the
best version of yourself what we learn
over of course the movie is they won the
war years ago and the scrolls are living
as refugees and the Cree are kind of
hounding them mercilessly
the handful of us that left will be
swatted next unless you help me finish
what Novell started she's trying to
break out
this movie is very much about the
journey of discovery caryl learned that
she's not who she thought she was she
learns that the war that she was
fighting is not what she thought and the
characters who have in the movie are on
that journey too
this movie is really about heart and we
as an audience go on this amazing
emotional journey hi everyone its
charlie we have a whole bunch of
Avengers endgame Marvel phase four stuff
to talk about so if you're brand new to
the channel be sure to subscribe to get
all the Marvel videos there's gonna be
way crazier this summer with spider-man
far from home and then us getting the
official Marvel phase four scheduled at
Comic Con there's gonna be a huge Marvel
Comic Con panel this year we're doing a
new round of the Infinity Gauntlet
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave an Avengers
comment on the video so big thing people
were asking after Avengers endgame is
what is the deal with Captain Marvel
rescuing Ironman when did that happen
because they don't address that at all
usually you see a post-credits scene
from a previous movie like the Captain
Marvel post-credits scene where she
shows up usually they have a scene at
the beginning of the next movie which is
Avengers end game where they explain
what they're gonna do next okay great
Iron Man's stuck out there why don't you
go pick him up and bring him back so
what the timeline is is the Captain
Marvel shows up at the end of Avengers
end game answering the page as they're
learning about all the people who Thanos
snaps so this is right after the events
of the snap in Wakanda they've come back
to the Avengers base Captain America
still has his crazy long beard the
reason why they were able to find Nick
Fury's pager is is because they were
tracking Nick Fury his car has special
technology in it remember all the way
back to Winter Soldier he drives very
special James Bond style cars they knew
about the ashes so they probably assumed
that when they found no Nick Fury nearby
all of his technology his bags his
enormous enact like everyone else
the pager would have been right there on
the ground so they picked it up and even
though they didn't know what it was they
just jacked it into their power source
so they could keep it going because they
sensed that Nick Fury was trying to use
it to find someone or bring someone back
so they just wanted to find out who that
person was that's why Black Widow has
the line I want to find out who's on the
other end of that pager in the surprise
she turns around and boomed
captain Marple when you pick up at the
beginning of Avengers and game right
after the title sequence on the Benatar
with Ironman and nebula the way Ironman
explains it is it it's been a couple
weeks since the snap that they've been
stuck in outer space so it's a couple
weeks after Captain Marvel shows up at
the Avengers base so you have to assume
that during that couple week period they
were just catching Captain Marvel up in
the last 20 years of Earth history what
happened with Thanos in the snap because
she would have also seen all the people
around her increased scroll space just
completely disappear into Ashe not
understanding what's going on eventually
they probably figured out that Iron Man
was stuck in outer space and they knew
that the last place they saw him was on
Titan so that's probably why they sent
Captain Marvel to go get him and it
probably just took her a while to find
him so it's not like she instantly found
him in the way they explained her
ability to fly through space without a
helmet in the Captain Marvel movie is
that it's when she's fully charged up
and as long as she has a map for where
she needs to go she could also fly
through those wormholes that you see all
over the place in space they kind of set
those up during guardians of the galaxy
vol 2 when they grew through that giant
montage going through all those portals
all the way to ego the Living Planet
anyway before I was so rudely
interrupted that's sort of the way they
get around the idea of hyperspace in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe because faster
than light travel is kind of complicated
so they just explain it that there's a
bunch of wormholes and they travel
really fast that's how you get from one
into the universe to the other without
it taking forever but it still does take
them a while to travel so it's not like
all these things of her showing up at
the Avengers base then showing up at the
bennet are happening one right after the
other within the span of five minutes
you're looking at like a couple weeks
worth of travel the other big clip in
this is obviously just explaining the
scrolls within the Marvel Cinematic
Universe the way Kevin Feige talks about
it is they just wanted to do something
unexpected with the scrolls during the
Captain Marvel movie like surprise this
is all about false memories and people
being gas-lit so wouldn't it be funny if
this evil Marvel race that's been so
infamous in Marvel comic book history
winds up being good in this movie in
that we meet the evil scrolls later on
where they can do Avengers secret
invasion the way he explained it is
obviously this is all happening twenty
years ago during the Captain Marvel
movie is it we just haven't met the evil
scrolls yet and because of what happens
with the snaps in Avengers infinity war
in Avengers endgame it's a really easy
way to explain how evil scroll factions
within their race and the super scroll
come about later on because obviously
they're gonna do Captain Marvel sequel
I'll talk about the Marvel phase four
schedule in a second they're probably
gonna save the introduction of evil
scrolls for the Captain Marvel sequel
which probably won't happen for a couple
more years so we're talking like mid to
late phase four after that is when they
can finally do an Avengers secret
invasion movie they haven't said whether
or not Ben Mendelsohn's Talos character
is coming back they didn't explain
exactly how Scrolls aged within the
Marvel Cinematic Universe if they're
very long-lived like some of the other
space-based races it would be pretty
easy to explain that's how you bring his
character back they haven't said exactly
when the Captain Marvel sequel is going
to take place in the timeline but it
does sound like it'll just be a little
while after the events of the first
Captain Marvel movie so that they can
pay off her T's at the end of that like
Ronan says we're coming back for the
woman the weapon later
so obviously they'll pay that off in
another movie that said during the past
because Ronan is dead in present day but
she also sends Yann raagh off at the end
of that movie saying tell this
Preem intelligence that i'm coming to
end the war and all the lies so thought
to pay that off during the sequel to but
no matter her power it's a very Superman
type of problem no matter how powerful
you are you can't solve everyone's
problems you can't change the nature of
people you can hope to inspire them and
maybe that will change them later on but
it's not like she can completely end
that war all by herself right now the
Marvel phase four movie schedules that
we know about is Spider Man far from
home which they've kind of been back and
forth on is that a Phase three movie is
that gonna be a phase four movie right
now they're saying it's tail end phase
three because there's so much of an end
tag for Iron Man's time in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe there's the Black
Widow movie eternals which are both
premiering next year Doctor Strange two
guardians of the galaxy three Black
Panther two the Captain Marvel sequel
like I said and then an ant-man in the
wasp sequel ant-man the wasp three or
whatever you want to call it
most of those movies will be set in
present-day after the events of Avengers
end game so that's 2023 some of the
movies will be set during the past
though so like the Captain Marvel sequel
the Eternals movie is supposed to be set
during the past the Black Widow movie is
also supposed to be set during the past
because she's dead in present day and
we're not gonna be doing an alternate
universe version of her
there was talk recently about Marvel
doing in Ultimates
team up during Marvel phase four which
is sort of a Captain Marvel led spin-off
version of The Avengers with a couple
new characters that do a lot of really
big cosmic things if they don't wind up
doing Avengers phase five and
introducing the new Avengers roster til
Marvel phase five what they'll probably
do is turn one of these really big
Marvel movies like Black Panther 2 into
a Captain America Civil War mini
Avengers movie where you put a whole
bunch of really big characters in it
that's still wide open to speculation
about what those team ups would be but
they'll still do the thor ragnarok
crossover buddy style movies where you
have at least one or two avengers
teaming up in a big movie so regardless
of when the next Avengers movie happens
with Avengers actually in the title of
the movie they'll still be a lot of
Avengers crossover stuff happening in
these movies and you have all the
Avengers spin-off TV series that'll be
happening during Marvel phase for a year
to year that will integrate with what's
going on in the movies too Kevin Feige
did reveal that the TV series that
they're doing for Disney Plus will push
the plot of The Avengers forward within
the Marvel
maduk universe so if you're wondering
when they're actually gonna do in
Avengers secret invasion movie because a
lot of people are already thinking
forward to Avengers secret Wars which is
an even bigger concept where you
collapse the multiverse into one single
reality then exploded back out at the
end Secret Wars is so big that they
probably wait till after the next two or
three phases before they do something
like that so they would probably do
Secret Invasion before they do Secret
Wars so anytime after Avengers 5 but I
wouldn't be surprised that they wait
till Avengers 6 to do Secret Invasion
let me know in the comments though when
do you actually want them to start doing
Secret Invasion stuff within the Marvel
Cinematic Universe they teased it a
little bit during Captain Marvel but the
big twist was is they weren't evil
trying to infiltrate earth they were
just trying to hide out and for those of
you that are still confused about how
Marvel got the tesseract she actually
got it from Howard Stark when they
started project Pegasus Howard Stark
began that program at the Secret
Avengers facility that they blew up at
the beginning of the first Avengers film
he's the one that brought Marvel on to
the project because Marvel showed up
pretending to be a really smart person
when really she was a Kree searching for
the tesseract so Howard Stark
effectively gave her the tesseract until
she turned into a good character and
realized how the Kree were going to be
evil she was trying to help the scrolls
out so that's why she was in possession
of that during the Captain Marvel movie
once Goose the cat puked it up at the
end of Captain Marvel and that last
post-credits tag Nick Fury just took
that back to the project Pegasus
facility where they continued to study
it there'll be a whole bunch more Marvel
stuff posting this week I have a bunch
more Avengers videos that I'm working on
leave your requests in the comments
below
congratulations iron chimp you're the
giveaway winner from my last big Marvel
video please email me on the about page
of my channel so I can get your details
click here for the new spider-man far
from home trailer and click here to
rewatch that Iron Man spider-man
Avengers in game to leave it seen a
billion more times thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]